翻訳: Toshihiro Suzuki
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
皆さん
今日いくつぐらいものを持ってますか
ちょっと数えてみてもらっていいですか
とりあえず着ている服 １枚の人
流石にいませんよね
たぶん２枚以上だと思います ここで ２
鞄の中身いくつぐらい入ってますか
スマートフォン入ってますか
鍵入ってますか
靴履いてらっしゃいますか
たくさんものを持ってますよね
ひょっとしたらペースメーカーのように
体の中に埋め込む
そんな機械をお持ちの方も
いらっしゃるかもしれません
私たちは
こんなことがあったらいいなぁとか
こんな技術があったらいいなぁ
って思うことを
自分たちの力でどんどん生み出して
この社会をこんなに豊かにしてきました
周りを見るとものが溢れていて
ひょっとしたら もう
私たち必要なものを
全部作り尽くしちゃったんじゃないか
と思うぐらい
ものに溢れてものに囲まれて暮らしています
ですけれど
まだ ものづくりが
その力を発揮しきっていない領域があります
どこだと思われますか？
それはソーシャルビジネスと呼ばれる領域です
社会の困り事を仕事を通じて解決する
そんなふうな領域です
ここでは普段
ものづくりではあまり作られない
ようなものが必要で
且つこのマーケットが小さいので
今までビジネスの領域では
あまり着目されてきませんでした
でも確実に困っている人がいて
そこの困り事は
ものづくりの力で
ひょっとしたら解決できるかもしれないんです
ものづくりで
困っている人の
今の困り事を解決することができて
その人たちが幸せになったら
とても素敵な仕事だと思いませんか
私は今
髪の毛が抜けてしまう時期を過ごす
そんな皆さんが集まる
専門の美容室を運営しています
ここでは帽子やウィッグといった
商品を販売しているんですけれど
ものを販売するだけではなくて
これがあなたの人生をどう変えていくのか
それを一緒に考えることをとても大切にした
少し変わった美容室です
ここにいらっしゃる方たちは
自分らしさが急に変わる体験をしています
髪の毛がある日突然抜けてくるんです
自分の見た目が急に変わると
自分らしさもとっても揺らいでしまいます
自分らしさが揺らぐと
人はとても不安になるんです
不安を抱えながら
毎日毎日暮らしていくのは
本当に辛いことです
生きにくいです
その生きにくさを抱えている人たちを
私は毎日 この場所で一緒に
考えたり 悩んだり
時々泣いてみたりしています
私がこの仕事を始めてから
自らの意思で
自ら
自分の髪の毛を全部剃ってみたことがあります
写真ではかなり笑ってますけど
かなり憂鬱な体験でした
あ 笑ってもいいですよ （笑）
あの〜 高校球児みたいでしょ？
でもこれだと
すごく生きにくいし 注目されるし
なんか自分もとっても憂鬱だったので
その時期はウィッグを使って過ごしていました
見た目が変わるっていうのは
本当に生きにくいことなんだなって
この時によく分かりました
この時期 本当に
生き辛かったことは覚えているんですけれど
私はこの時 髪がなかっただけなんです
自分で剃って髪がないだけ
だけれど
私たちの美容室にやってくる方々は
髪がない
その理由に病気や何かがあるんです
髪がないだけでもこんなに憂鬱なのに
さらにその原因でもっと憂鬱なんです
とっても生きにくい時期だと私は思っています
自分で髪の毛を剃ってみて
確実に一つだけわかったことがあります
それは ものがあるだけでは
人は気持ちを前に向けることができない
ということです
このものを使って
じゃあ これで 明日から
もう一度自分らしく生きてみようって
自分自身が心に決めないと
ものは全然その力を発揮しないんです
でも もので一緒に生きて行こうって
前向きな気持ちになると
ものは時々 ものすごく強い力を発揮します
必要な人に ちょうどいいタイミングで
必要なものが 心地よく提供されると
そのものは 最大の効果を発揮します
私がこの仕事を始めたきっかけを
少しお話させてください
私が看護学生だったころ
この手紙をくださった患者さんが
白血病の末期の患者さんでした
女性の方で
薬の副作用で
髪の毛も
まゆ毛も まつ毛も
全部抜けて
何もない状態で
残された時間も
あと１年もありませんでした
その方が
たぶん最後のチャンスになる外泊の時に
自分の姿で人に心配をされずに
人に会いたいって
リクエストをくださったんです
それでウィッグを検討したんですけど
結局 彼女は
それを買うことができませんでした
その時に彼女から言われた言葉が
死にゆく私がこれ以上お金を使うと
これからも生きていく家族が困るから
これ以上お金は使いたくないって言われました
私ものすごくショックでした
あぁ 無力だなあと思いました
結局 彼女は
季節外れのアクリルの
ニットの帽子をかぶって退院をされて
帽子姿では人に心配をかけるからと
ほとんど外出もせずに過ごしたそうです
私はこの時
彼女の
心配をされずに大切な人に会いたい
ただそれだけの願いを
叶えることができませんでした
何がいけなかったのかを考えてみました
ウィッグはそこにありました
でも患者さんが
頃合いよく
買って使うことができませんでした
そういう仕組みになっていなかったんです
これ 解決しないと
みんなとっても生きにくくて
しょうがないですよね
なので
患者さんが 必要な時に
必要なものを買って使える
そんな仕組みを
自分で作ることにチャレンジしました
その時に もちろん
メーカーさんを説得してみたり
社会活動をしようかなっていうことも
少し考えましたけれど
なんだか難しそうだし
時間もかかりそうだし
とにかく早くやった方が
みんな納得するだろうなぁって思ったので
自分で作ってみることにしたんです
それで いろいろ調べてみたら
当時 世界中のウィッグの７割は
中国で作られていました
ですから中国の工場を200社ぐらい
がーっとリストアップして
そこに一斉にメールを送って
最後は自分でそこに行って
とにかく気合と根性で
ウィッグを作ってもらいました
それが 最初の私のものづくりの
現場との出会いです
ところで
私はさっきからものづくりと言ってますが
皆さんものづくりって何かご存知ですか
ものづくりこんなもんだよ
って答えられる方って
どのぐらい いらっしゃいますか
あてませんよ
（笑）
ものづくりっていうのは 簡単に言うと
技術を使って材料を何か違うものに変えていく
そんなことです
工場で同じものを1000個作るのも
この写真のように料理をするのも
同じくものづくりです
料理をする時には
皆さん
家族や友人
恋人とか 食べてくれる人の
美味しそうで 幸せそうな顔を
想像しながら作りませんか
私たちは日常で
自分たちが作り出したもので
人が幸せになっていく
そんなシーンを想像しながら
ものづくりをしているんです
じゃあ これ
同じように仕事でもできそうな気がしませんか
仕事のものづくりでも
これってできないでしょうか
残念ながら 現在のものづくりでは
ものを作ることと販売することの効率を求めて
そんなに余裕がありません
ものを使って
作ったものを使って
そしてそれで幸せになっていくシーンに
なかなか出会うことができないんです
この写真の女性は
車椅子に乗っています
がんの末期の患者さんで
脊椎に転移していて立つことができません
ウィッグを使っています
でもウィッグというものがあるおかげで
この素敵な笑顔で
娘さんの結婚式に出ることができました
家族と一緒に
素敵な時間を過ごすことができました
この写真を見て皆さん
ものづくり凄いと思いませんか？
だってこれ それがなかったら
この人丸坊主ですよ
これがあるから
あぁ 良かったねってみんな思えます
この方が亡くなった後も
きっと皆の心の中に素敵なシーンが残ります
私たちはこうして 日常
ものを使って人が幸せになっていく
シーンに出会っています
ものづくりの皆さんは
ここに出会うことは難しいかもしれませんが
私たちのような
現場のプロフェッショナルと
ものを作ってらっしゃる皆さんとが
もっと歩み寄って 協力をしあったら
ここの問題って
クリアーできるような気がしませんか
私たちが現場で感じている
ちょうどいい頃合い
これを製品設計に
フィードバックしていただいて
ものづくりのプロの皆さんが
設計や改良をしてくれたら
使う人たちのことを本当に考えた
人が幸せになるようなものづくりを
していくことができないでしょうか
私たちはそれをここでやっています
ここは私たちの美容室ですが
ここにいらっしゃる患者さんたちは
髪の毛が抜けていく
そんな時期を過ごす人たちです
皆さんにウィッグや帽子の説明はしますが
一番大事なことは
私が これを使って
この時期をどうやって過ごしていくのか
シーンを想像してもらうことなんです
例えば
抗がん剤を使い始めて
何日ぐらいで髪の毛が抜けますか
子供さんと一緒に外出する時は
ウィッグか 帽子か
それとも帽子のつけ毛がいいのか
髪の毛が少し生え始めると
ウィッグが動きやすくなるんですけど
その時に
私はどうやってそれを
工夫をしていくのか
そして一番大事なことは
髪の毛が生えてきて
このウィッグを卒業していくのはいつ頃なのか
そんな ものを使うシーンと
時期を想像してもらって
本人が じゃあこのもので
私この時期乗り切るぞって
気持ちになってもらうことです
そしてその人が
そのものを使いながら
生きにくい時期を必死で過ごしていくんです
社会の中には
困り事を抱えながら生きている人が
少なからず存在しています
例えば 今日本には
がんの治療をしながら
日常生活を送っている人が
約150万人いらっしゃいます
私たちはその患者さんの日常生活のこと
ばっかり考えているかなりのマニアです
しかもレアなマニアです
こういったマニアは
各業界にいます
そして このマニアが担っているのが
ソーシャルビジネスという領域です
でも私たちは残念ながら
ものづくりをするプロではありません
だから どんなにニーズを知っていても
どんなにソリューションが思い付いても
人の人生を変えてしまうような
素敵なものを作り出すことはできないんです
そこで皆さんに今日お願いがあります
私たちのようなマニアと一緒に
是非 ソーシャルビジネスという領域に
一緒にチャレンジをして
いただけないでしょうか
確かにマーケットのサイズは小さいですが
本当に困っている人がいて
皆さんの作った製品が
その人の困り事を解決して
病気にはなったけど
これがあるから 毎日私らしく生きていける
そんなふうに言ってもらえたら
この仕事
めちゃくちゃ面白くなると思いませんか
それはひょっとしたら
使い古された技術を使った
とても小さくて
とてもシンプルな製品かもしれません
でもそれが もし人の人生を変えちゃうなら
これって立派なイノベーションですよね
ものづくりの技術って
人の幸せのためにあるんです
そして
ものづくりは人を幸せにする力があります
私は今まで 現場で
ものに出会って
ものに助けられて
笑顔に戻っていく人たちに
たくさん会ってきました
この現場の感動を作ってくれているのは
ものづくりに携わっている皆さんが
作ってくれた
素敵なもののおかげなんです
私たちが日々感じている社会の困り事
これを一緒にシェアして
そしてそれによって
私たちが日々感じている
この現場の感動もシェアして
ものづくりの技術が
人を幸せにしていける
そんな技術の循環を
一緒に作っていってください
（拍手）